FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi everyone,
I'm Kat.
I am with the Authors@Google
program here
at Google Los Angeles.
Welcome.
We're very happy to host
professor Kal Raustiala today.
Professor Raustiala is a
professor at UCLA Law School
and also a director at Ronald
W. Burkle Center for
International Relations
at UCLA.
Professor Raustiala is a
graduate of Harvard Law
School, and he is also a
frequent media contributor to
publications like "The Wall
Street Journal," "The New
Yorker," "The New York Times,"
and "The Financial Times." His
latest book, written with
Christopher Sprigman, is
called "The Knockoff Economy,"
and it was published in
September 2012, this year.
And we're very happy
to have him today.
He's going to talk a little
bit about how copying and
imitation actually spurs
creativity and innovation.
Welcome, professor.
[APPLAUSE]
KAL RAUSTIALA: Thank you.
KAL RAUSTIALA: OK,
thanks, everyone.
As Kat just said, this book,
which I did write with a
co-author who teaches at UVA,
is really about copyright,
patent, and how they connect to
innovation and creativity,
so issues that I think would be
of interest here at Google.
So I'm really glad to have the
opportunity to come here.
I've never been to
this building.
I've driven by it
a million times.
So it's great to be here.
Let me start off with a few just
basic points about what
we try to do in the book.
And then I'm going to run
through some examples to give
you a taste.
But the basic gist of the book
is that we are interested in
how copying affects the
incentives to create and how
it helps sustain or undermine
creativity.
So I think, as many of you
know, the underlying idea
behind our intellectual property
system is that
copying is bad for creativity.
That's the basic concept.
Copies usually out-compete
originals because they're
cheaper than the originals.
And so we restrict that form of
competition by awarding a
copyright or a patent.
I'm going to mostly talk
about copyright today.
But we restrict that competition
and give the
originator a window of time in
which they have a monopoly
over that design.
So in the case of patent,
it's 20 years.
In the case of copyright, it
sort of depends, but it's
much, much longer.
So that's the basic gist of our
system, and it's been that
way since the framers of the
Constitution first put in a
clause about the need to promote
progress in the useful
sciences and arts.
So that's the underlying
concept.
So what we're interested in in
this book is not whether or
not that's true.
We think that that's generally
true, and we're generally
supportive of intellectual
property.
Some people do actually argue
for the abolition of copyright
and patent.
We don't really do that.
But we are interested in whether
it's truly necessary
to have these copyrights and
patents in place, these
monopoly rights protected by the
government, to have those
in place to have sustained
creativity.
When that's true, why it's
true, to what degree it's
true, some of those sorts
of questions.
And the way that we come at it
in the book is a little bit
different than most work
that's been done.
So a lot of people who look at
these issues focus on things
like the music industry.
This has been a hot issue for
a long time, really, ever
since Napster.
And so people have been really
interested in, what happened
to the music industry,
and is online
downloading a bad thing?
Most people say yes, some
people say it's a
good thing, et cetera.
They debate it by looking at
copyright-protected industries
or, increasingly, the film and
television industries.
We don't really do that, though
we do have an epilogue
at the end of the book
about music.
What we do instead is look at
industries that don't have
intellectual property
protection, and we try to
understand what happens
in those industries.
How do they operate?
How do they sustain
their innovation?
And those industries are
somewhat unusual.
So I'm going to start off today
with one that I think
exemplifies sort of the
flavor of the book.
And that's the fashion
industry.
So I'm going to guess that a
lot of you are not frequent
shoppers at Faviana.
Maybe you've been to
other stores--
so Faviana actually does
not even have a
brick-and-mortar store.
It's just a website.
They sell to other places.
And you directly
order dresses.
But what's important about
Faviana, and you can see from
this website, is its
whole business
model is knocking off.
So typically, one of their
big business areas are
girls going to a prom.
They go to one of these
pictures, they say oh, I saw
Angelina Jolie on the red carpet
at the Oscars last year
wearing this great dress.
I want to have that dress.
And then they can order it.
It's not the same dress.
It's going to be significantly
cheaper.
It might be a few hundred
dollars rather than a few
thousand dollars or maybe even
tens of thousands of dollars
for the original.
It's not going to look
exactly the same.
The material might not
be exactly the same.
But it's a pretty
close facsimile.
And that's their basic
business model.
You can see similar sorts of
things if you walk into
Forever 21.
Now, some of you may
have done that.
So if you go into a Forever
21, you'll see lots of
examples of knocked-off
designs.
And I want to pause for a moment
just to explain what I
mean by a knockoff versus
a counterfeit.
So if you buy a dress or a pair
of sunglasses in a place
like Santee Alley downtown or
Canal Street in New York, and
you see a fake label that says,
like, Prada, or maybe
Prado, or some version like
that, that's a counterfeit.
So what they're trying to do is
say, hey, you think you're
buying this Prada handbag or
pair of sunglasses, but you're
really not.
You're buying something else.
That's counterfeit, and that's
really dealing with trademark
and the brand.
What we're talking about here
is the actual design.
So the look of the dress that
Angelina Jolie's wearing in
that picture, or Megan Fox, the
way it's cut, the design,
the shape, et cetera--
those things are all completely
legal to copy.
So the counterfeit example
is absolutely illegal.
The design, however, is
completely legal to copy.
And it's been that way in the
United States forever.
We've never protected fashion
designs from copying.
So the fashion industry has for
decades operated without
any effective intellectual
property protection over its
core product, which is the
look of the actual--
and it's not just dresses,
obviously.
Any kind of clothing, accessory,
and so forth,
without any protection
for that.
And what's interesting
about that is it's a
pretty vibrant industry.
And I want to just take a
moment just to say that
knocking off is not limited to
companies like Faviana or, for
that matter, Forever 21.
So this is drawn from "US
Weekly" a few months ago.
And you can find features like
this in a lot of these kinds
of magazines.
So one actress is wearing
the original.
One's wearing a copy.
The copy's always
much cheaper.
I shouldn't say always--
often much cheaper.
It depends.
But typically, it is
significantly cheaper.
And these kind of knockoffs
are everywhere.
And since I mentioned Forever
21, I'll give you an example,
in a moment, of a Forever
21 example.
But so you can see these outfits
look pretty similar.
From a distance, you could
not tell the difference.
So these copies are
quite similar.
Now again, just to step back
to where I began, I think
you've all seen this warning.
And this warning gets at the
underlying principles of our
system of intellectual
property.
So why is it not only illegal
but, in fact, a criminal
offense to make a copy?
Because we think that protecting
against copies is
such a significant factor in
our intellectual property
system that we have to police
it in that way.
So that makes the fashion
industry really unusual--
though it's only one chapter
in the book, and I'll go
through some of the
other examples.
It's not unique.
It's just unusual.
So I mentioned Forever 21.
So this is an example we talk
about in "The Knockoff
Economy." So the dress on
the left, I believe--
I can't even tell, because they
look so much alike-- is
the original.
The one on the right is the
Forever 21 version.
So the original sold for maybe
$400 a few years ago.
The copy sold for about $40.
Paris Hilton wore the dress on
David Letterman, and all of a
sudden, orders started flooding
in to Forever 21.
It became a big thing.
But again, the designers
could do absolutely
nothing about it.
That's just the way
of the industry.
OK, so how does fashion work?
What makes it work
as a system?
To make the point clear, why
is it that this kind of
copying is not destroying the
incentive to create in the
fashion industry in the way that
our intellectual property
system supposes?
And I'll give you two
basic answers.
There's a much longer version
of this, obviously, in the
book, but two basic things
to think about.
The first is that fashion has
some special qualities that
are grounded in the fact that
it is something that's
expressive and public and has
a status component to it.
Now, a lot of us don't pay
attention to fashion.
We don't really care about it.
That's sort of one end
of the spectrum.
There's a middle group of people
who do care a little
bit, and then there's
a small group of
people who care a lot.
So people divide up
in those ways.
For people who really care
about fashion, this
status-expressive component is
really significant for the
following reason.
So we've known for, really,
centuries that things come
into style, and they
go out of style.
So Shakespeare talked about the
fashion wearing out more
apparel than the man in "Much
Ado About Nothing."
And what Shakespeare was getting
at was the idea that
you don't typically
wear your clothes
until they're destroyed.
You wear them until you're kind
of sick of them, or until
somebody tells you you've
really got to
get rid of that thing.
And you get something new, or
you just feel like it's time.
So that's how most of us change
our clothes, for the
most part, especially in a place
like the United States.
It's not because we're
wearing them out.
It's because there's something
new out there, some
new style out there.
So things come into style, they
go out of style, that's
the fashion cycle.
That's been long recognized.
What's important, and I think
relatively unrecognized--
this is what we emphasize in our
book-- is that the freedom
to copy that flows from the fact
that our copyright law
does not address fashion, means
that that fashion cycle
can turn even faster.
And the reason that it turns
even faster is that once a
dress like this comes into style
and Forever 21 copies
it, now the original might have
sold a few hundred, maybe
even a thousand, maybe a couple
of thousand copies.
That's it.
But the copy sold tens of
thousands, maybe hundreds of
thousands of versions.
So it spreads out into the
marketplace very quickly.
And so now the people who spent
$400 on the original
start to see, maybe, the girl
down the street wearing the
$40 version.
And they're kind of annoyed
about that, and they're
annoyed that it's everywhere.
And we spoke to the designers
of this original dress, and
they were peeved.
And they talked about customers
coming in and
complaining that they had chosen
it for some event or a
bridesmaid's dress or whatever
it might be, and now the
specialness had been destroyed
by the copy.
So what effect does that have?
Well, it drives people to
go and say, well, I want
something new.
I want something different.
I'm not going to keep wearing
this dress anymore.
So in other words,
it makes that
fashion cycle turn faster.
And so designers then have to
offer something faster.
So in fashion, unlike
technology, the new, new thing
is not better in any way.
It's just different.
Clothing doesn't improve
in any meaningful way.
Sometimes people come up with a
new fabric that repels heat
or water or something--
that's unusual.
Most of it is just
sort of changes.
And so how you get people to
get a new phone is you tell
them, hey, this newer phone has
a million features that
your old phone didn't have, so
get rid of your old phone.
With clothing, you have to
have some other means to
induce that desire for
consumers to buy.
And that's partly driven
by the ability to copy.
And that relates to a second
point, which is trends.
So if we think about the fashion
industry, it's a
trend-driven industry.
There are trends, and if you
read magazines like "US
Weekly" or "Vogue"--
again, I'm going to guess
a lot of us don't.
But if you do, if you look
in those, you'll see that
there'll be discussions of
what's in style this season,
what's coming in next season,
what was on the runway, et
cetera, et cetera.
So trends are a major
part of fashion.
And if you think about a trend,
a trend is just a
series of things that
look alike.
That's what makes it a trend.
It's a bunch of things that
are similar in some way.
So here again, the freedom to
copy that our copyright system
allows the fashion industry also
allows trends to develop.
And as those trends develop,
they give people something to
latch onto if they want to
be stylishly dressed.
So they could say, OK, the trend
this season is X. I'm
going to follow X.
So it also helps with the kind
of information gathering issue
for fashion consumers.
What is it you buy in a
marketplace that offers
thousands of choices?
Trends help kind
of define that.
So the bottom line is copying
has a paradoxical effect in
the fashion industry.
It doesn't drive
out creativity.
It actually promotes it.
It acts like this turbocharger,
spinning that
fashion cycle faster and faster
and leading designers
to come up with new designs
even faster.
So far from destroying
innovation, it's promoting it.
Now, fashion is not alone
in doing that.
Here's an example of something
I'm guessing a lot of you have
eaten at some point
or another, right?
So the molten chocolate cake.
If you look at the world of
cuisine, it's surprisingly
similar to the fashion world.
The molten chocolate cake,
whether the recipe or the cake
itself, is unprotected by
copyright or patent.
So for example, a recipe
is, strictly speaking,
uncopyrightable.
So if you buy a cookbook, the
cookbook is copyrightable.
And the stuff around the recipe,
where the chef says,
well, I was vacationing in
Tuscany, and I saw this
wonderful--
that kind of stuff is
all copyrightable.
But the actual recipe
itself is not.
So that's why you can go
online to a place like
Epicurious or cooks.com or any
of these websites and find
tons and tons of examples
of recipes.
Totally legal.
Likewise, you can walk
into a restaurant and
say, I love this dish.
And if you're a good chef, you
can reverse engineer that
dish, figure out what the
components are, what the
techniques are, and then make
it yourself, and maybe even
serve it at the restaurant
across the street.
Totally legal to do.
And as a result, things like
this get invented and then
migrate around.
So there's a little bit of a
dispute over who the true
inventor of the molten
chocolate cake is.
But many people would place it
in a restaurant on the Upper
East Side of Manhattan in
sort of the late 1980s.
And now you can find
this in Chili's.
And you can, in fact, find the
Chili's recipe online.
You can find it in almost
any restaurant today.
If you've had miso-glazed
black cod--
I'm guessing some people
have eaten that dish.
Somebody invented that somewhere
in Japan, and it
spreads out.
And there are example after
example like that.
So nothing stops the
copying of cuisine.
Does it mean that copying
has driven out
creativity in cuisine?
No.
I think actually the opposite.
I think today we live in
probably the most creative
time ever for cuisine.
And there's incredibly inventive
cooking going on.
So there's some very basic and
delicious and excellent
cooking going on.
If any of you have been to
Bazaar on La Cienega, you know
what I'm talking about, right?
So people are coming up with
extremely creative dishes
using new techniques,
in some cases.
And just as a footnote, some
of those techniques can be
patented, but most aren't.
But the dishes themselves, as
long as you can figure out how
to do it and you have
the right tools, you
can recreate them.
So just like in the fashion
world, the culinary world has
not been destroyed by copying.
And in fact, if you talk to
chefs-- and in the book, we
discuss many examples and also
quote from many of the chefs
that we interviewed, great chefs
here and in New York.
And also, we draw on some other
studies that looked at
places like Paris.
If you talk to chefs, they're
very divided on this issue.
Some of them feel that they're
artists, much like fashion
designers sometimes feel.
They're artists, and their art
should be protected the same
as music would be protected,
the same as poetry is
protected, the same as novels
are protected, et cetera, et
cetera-- paintings.
Others think-- and I think this
is the majority view--
that innovation is assisted by
an open framework, which you
can view as roughly akin to a
kind of open-source model of
innovation.
So rather than saying, I own
this molten chocolate cake,
and you cannot copy it, or for
that matter, produce anything
that's substantially similar,
which is our legal standard
for copyright, to it, instead
a lot of chefs believe that
the ability to share and to
trade and to tweak and to
improve upon what others have
done actually produces more
creativity and better products
in the long run.
And that openness is promotive
of innovation, not destructive
of innovation.
So the world of chefs
is quite similar.
Let me just add one other
point about chefs.
I mentioned Paris.
One of the things we talk about
in the "The Knockoff
Economy" is a very interesting
study by two people at MIT who
went and interviewed high-end
chefs in Paris.
These are chefs that had
Michelin-starred restaurants.
If you know about the Michelin
system, you know even one star
is a huge deal.
So these all had at least
one star or more.
And these chefs had a system
of social norms amongst
themselves, so the
study argued--
and we think it's a
well-done study--
that constrain the types of
copying that took place, but
really focused not so much on
restricting copying but on how
you copied.
And the key issue is
really attribution.
It was perfectly fine to copy a
cake or much more elaborate
dishes, as long as you
attributed it to the
originator.
So it's a little bit like the
labeling issue I talked about
with fashion.
As long as you don't tweak the
trademark, that's fine.
So I'll come back to this
issue of brands
versus designs later.
This is a football formation.
Now again, football is not an
industry we normally think of
as being driven by
or undergirded by
intellectual property.
But actually, the NFL has been
involved in a lot of IP cases.
They have huge investments
in their brands.
They have very good and very
high-priced lawyers.
They know all about intellectual
property.
However, what they haven't done
is been able to copyright
a formation, even though in
theory, there is a category
for choreographic works in our
copyright statute in the
United States.
And a football formation is
a form of choreography.
It just happens to involve
throwing a ball and hitting
people, rather than dancing
on a stage.
But is choreographic.
No one's been able to
successfully make this
argument to the copyright
office.
But substantively, they're
quite similar.
So put that aside
for a moment.
The fact is, formations and
plays are fully copyable.
Totally legal to copy a
formation and play.
Now again, does that stop
football coaches from coming
up with new formations?
No.
So we go through many examples
in the book where we talk
about things like--
some of them are very simple,
like the no-huddle offense,
where as it sort of suggests,
there's no huddle.
You just go from play to play
to play very quickly.
Quite effective.
To things that are more
complicated and variants on a
theme, so the spread, the spread
option, et cetera,
pioneered both at the college
level, sometimes even at the
high school level,
and in the NFL.
Now again, why is it that the
ability to copy a formation
doesn't stop coaches or
constrain them from creating
the way that our copyright
system assumes in most cases?
We think the answer is really
two-fold, and I'm going to
focus on one in particular.
The first is football is an
intensely competitive
enterprise.
So particularly when you're
talking about college football
and pro football, winning
or losing a single
game is a big deal.
And especially if that game is
something like the Super Bowl,
that's a career-winning issue.
There's also a powerful
first-mover
advantage in football.
So if you think about a
formation or a play, it's easy
to say, hey, I see this play,
I understand it, I'm
going to copy it.
What's difficult to do is
actually to get your team to
execute it well, and in some
cases, to build the proper
team that can execute this
type of play well.
So in other words, you may
need bigger or smaller
players, faster players,
different types of players.
That may take some
time to recruit.
So that's a marginal issue, but
it's not insignificant.
You also have to train.
You have to perfect it.
So there's a period of time
between the moment a new play
is unveiled on a field and the
time that competitors can
really use it to their
advantage.
So economists call that
first-mover advantage.
We see that in a lot
of industries.
And here, that natural
advantage, no laws involved in
that, gives enough of an
incentive, especially in a
very competitive industry, for
coaches to continue to create.
So here again, we see creativity
coupled to copying,
and the two seem to fit
very well together.
Now, is that a unique thing?
I'm going to argue
that it's not.
I'm going to just play
you something
quickly from this guy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Good artists copy.
Great artists steal.
And we have always been
shameless about
stealing great ideas.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KAL RAUSTIALA: OK, I don't know
if you could hear the
first thing.
He thinks he's quoting
Picasso.
It's not really clear that
Picasso ever said this.
But he's saying, good artists
copy, great artists steal, and
we at Apple have always been
shameless about stealing.
Now, that was Steve Jobs in the
'90s, I think roughly 1994
or so, when Apple was not
quite what it is today.
And of course, their
attitude--
in particular, his attitude--
about copying underwent quite
a transformation as Apple's
size and influence grew.
I think you all are familiar
with that.
But let me say a little bit
about this issue of stealing
and copying in other arenas, and
especially in technology.
So the examples that we talk
about in the book are
obviously unusual ones.
So food, fashion, et cetera,
these seem quite different
from something like inventing
the iPad.
And they are, but there are some
interesting similarities.
And I think when you step back
a little bit and think about
it, one of the things that all
of the examples that I've
given you so far feature is that
there's a system, a kind
of ecology of innovation in
which people can borrow from
what others have done
and improve upon
it by refining it.
So we call that in the book
tweaking versus pioneering.
So we kind of divide the world
of innovation into two types--
tweakers and pioneers.
And I think for most people,
their conventional
understanding of innovation is
that you want big new ideas
that are pioneering.
And so people think about
someone like Thomas Edison and
the light bulb, and
that's the kind of
thing we want to promote.
That's why we have a patent
system, to do that.
Now, if you stop and think
about even that example,
Thomas Edison didn't really
invent the light bulb.
So when he was putting out his
light bulb, there were already
over a dozen examples of light
bulbs in existence
that he drew upon.
What he did is he figured out
a better filament, bamboo,
that worked a little bit better
inside, so he was not
actually a pioneer in the way
that our lore has it.
He was tweaking existing ideas
and making them better and
making them workable.
Someone like Steve Jobs--
and I'm not limiting
this to him at all.
He's just a high-profile
example of this--
did a lot of the same things.
And I think a lot of innovation
is of this sort.
Now obviously, it's a
matter of degree.
But so I think most of you are
probably familiar with this.
Not a great picture, but if you
look at the top, you see
this crude early mouse.
And then at the bottom,
you see a series
of early Apple mice.
So that top mouse is the one
that was in the Xerox PARC
research facility that Steve
Jobs visited in the late '70s
in a famous trip.
The ones at the bottom are some
of his early, I would
say, tweaks of that mouse.
So if you think about both the
graphical user interface, the
mouse, the whole way that we
tend to think of computing
today, this is something that
the early components could be
found at Xerox PARC, the
things like this
kind of crude mouse.
And Jobs, being someone who,
as he said, was shameless
about stealing, didn't
hesitate to say, hey,
I really like that.
That's an amazing idea,
but it's not
that wonderfully executed.
I'm going to execute
it better.
And so over time, he slowly
executed it better and better
and better.
And I think that's
a good example of
the power of tweaking.
Now to do that, he had to copy
some fundamental attributes.
And in those days, yes, patents
were available for
hardware, but they were not
nearly as thick or as commonly
given or as broad as
they see today.
So if you were to try to do
the equivalent in today's
legal climate, you would run
into a thicket of patents.
And that's the phrase that
lawyers often use-- "patent
thickets." There's so many of
them in each component,
whatever it might be-- a mouse,
a computer, the CPU--
thousands and thousands and
thousands of patents
overlapping and interacting and
causing barriers that you
have to overcome through
licensing deals or worry about
being sued by a patent troll.
So there's a lot of difficulties
involved in this
kind of basic improvement, which
presupposes some degree
of copying.
Likewise in the copyright
context.
Same kinds of thing.
And also, by the way, in the
design context, when design
patents are at issue.
So in the Samsung-Apple
litigation that's been going
on all over the world, with
many different results--
I think most of you know,
up in Silicon
Valley, Apple prevailed.
In other countries, it's
been different.
So it varies.
There's been litigation in
Korea, in Japan, in the
Netherlands, in the
UK, et cetera.
But in those cases, what's
at stake are a
number of design patents.
And a design patent is a very
particular type of thing.
It is a patent, but it's
over a design feature.
So the ones that often get
talked about are things like
pinch-to-zoom.
But also included are the
actual shape of the eye
pattern in the iPhone.
So I have an iPhone
right here.
When you look at the shape, is
there anything really special
about the shape?
Well, it's a rectangle.
It's got rounded corners.
And this is very similar
to shape of the iPad.
The rectangle itself is not an
unusual shape for content
consumption.
So here's another example of a
rectangular content device.
Very basic.
I think when Moses brought the
tablets down, they were also
rectangular.
So this is not a new idea.
It's a tweak on an
existing idea.
Let's round the corners
a little bit.
Let's do a few other things.
Let's put this big
Home button here.
But that's it.
Nonetheless, Apple is claiming,
and in some cases,
succeeding on claiming, that
it has a design patent over
that particular shape--
I'm exaggerating
only slightly--
with some certain kind
of attributes.
And it's been able to uphold at
least some of those against
Samsung, in certain cases.
So I think the big point to take
home is that tweaking--
and the ability to tweak--
depends, in many cases, on
the ability to copy.
So whether we're talking about
industries where there's free
and legal copying like the
fashion industry, or we're
talking about things like high
technology, where there's not
free and legal copying, we still
want to think about what
is the right balance between
the ability to copy and
therefore to improve, to refine,
and the protection
that is often needed so that
innovators who are putting
money up, investing in their
innovation, can reap the
proper reward.
Not a fair reward, but the
reward that will keep them
innovating over time.
That is the critical issue.
So just to give you an example,
I was in Shanghai a
couple weeks ago.
Now if you take a close look,
you may notice that is not a
picture of an Apple on the
back of that phone.
It's the Peach.
So I think as some of you know,
in China today, there's
a vibrant, what's called the
"shanzai," culture of copying
in which a lot of copying
is taking place.
Now, this is a major issue
for American companies.
And there's a lot of
attention to it.
Since I'm at Google, I'll
throw out one anecdote.
We tried to get on Facebook in
our hotel in Shanghai, and you
know, just weren't really
thinking, little jet lag.
Try to get on Facebook, not
working, not working.
After the second time, a little
message popped up on
the Google page saying, "In
our experience, if you
continue to try to reach
Facebook, your access to the
internet will be shut
down." And we
stopped right after that.
And that was in a
Western hotel.
So thank you, Google,
for letting us know.
In any event, there's a lot of
copying like this going on.
Now, some of it is just
blatant mimicry.
But in some cases, there's some
interesting innovation.
So for example, the dual
SIM card cell phone.
So you have two SIM cards
inside, and that way you can
have two phone numbers.
It can work in two
jurisdictions, so this is a
big deal in China, where Hong
Kong actually is treated
administratively quite
differently
than the rest of China.
So in Shenzhen, right over the
border, there are all these
factories where they're putting
these things out.
And they are, in some cases,
tweaking and improving.
So there's a vibrant world
of that going on.
Now again, it is a problem to
some degree, but it's also a
solution in a sense, because
it's bringing us ideas that
hadn't existed before.
So I just want to come back to
what I said a moment ago.
It's about a question of
calibration and balance.
So we recognize-- and we talk
about this, I think, pretty
forthrightly in "The
Knockoff Economy"--
that copying has destructive
effects.
That's why we have intellectual
property laws.
But it also has productive
effects.
It has an upside.
And that upside is often
not appreciated fully.
So in part, the point
of the book is to
say, there is an upside.
And moreover, in a world in
which copying is ever more
common, like this, we want to
understand copying, because
fighting it doesn't actually
work very well.
Look at the music industry.
The music industry's been
fighting copying through
copyright law for over a decade,
and it has done very
little good for it.
I'll close on this note.
The music industry has, I think,
failed miserably at
stemming the perils
of copying for it.
Has that destroyed music?
Quite the opposite, right?
So if you think about music
today from the point of view
of us as consumers,
it's a golden age.
There's more music available,
online and elsewhere, than
ever before.
So 20 years ago, you walked
into the biggest record
store-- let's say Tower
Records up on Sunset--
it didn't have 1/100th of what
you could find in a second on
Amazon and iTunes and
any number of
other legal music sites.
So from a consumer's point of
view, there's tons of music,
great music, it's all out there,
much more accessible,
much more easily found.
From a producer point of view,
is it a worse situation?
Well, it depends.
If you ask certain acts who've
be around for a long time,
they'll say, yes,
it's terrible.
If you ask music industry
executives, they'll tell you
it's horrible.
But if you ask musicians,
it's divided.
So a lot of the same
technologies that allow for
the basic idea of the
internet, of digital
technologies, of home computing,
all those things
that permitted online copying
also permit production in your
bedroom with a couple of
software packages of an entire
album that would have, in the
past, required a studio,
expensive engineers, a
distribution network, physical
shipping of discs to places,
all of that.
Whereas today, you can do that
on your own, and you see many
examples of this.
So music has been both enabled
and disabled by these
disruptive technologies.
So even in the poster child for
the perils of copying, the
music industry, it's a more
mixed story than I think we
often acknowledge.
So I just want to close with
that, to say it's not just
about unusual industries like
the fashion industry.
There are important lessons,
I think, to be drawn across
these industries.
And that's what we try
to do in the book.
And I'm happy to talk about any
of those or spin out any
of these connections
in the Q&A.
So with that, I'm happy
to take questions.
Should I take my
own questions?
OK, sure.
AUDIENCE: Well, I was thinking
in particular with the fashion
and the food industry, and one
of the characteristics seemed
to be that innovation was
relatively quick and
inexpensive.
You didn't have to invest
a lot in designing a
new recipe or dress.
KAL RAUSTIALA: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Is that a
characteristic of the areas
where copying works better than
in places where you have
to invest a lot?
KAL RAUSTIALA: Yeah, that's
a great question.
Yes, it is a characteristic.
And one of the things that
we're careful to do is to
illustrate and to underscore
the point you just made.
There is a spectrum of
costs to creation.
So at one end of the spectrum,
if we think of this across all
forms, we might put the
pharmaceutical industry, where
there's maybe hundreds of
billions of dollars of upfront
cost into a particular
pharmaceutical.
Film can be almost
as expensive.
You think about a movie like
"Avatar," incredibly expensive.
So that's one end
of the spectrum.
The other end of the spectrum
is something where something
pops into your head
in a second.
That could include the music
industry, which has always
been fully protected.
Certainly poetry, other
forms of short-form
writing, and so forth.
But fashion and cuisine and
others that we discussed have
that attribute.
So there is definitely
a spectrum of cost.
Now the question is, what
do we do with that fact?
Our current intellectual
property system does
nothing with that.
If something falls under
copyright, whether it's music,
film, whatever, we treat
it the same way.
Likewise with patent.
We don't distinguish between
the patent length for--
there are some minor doctrines
that may allow for some
extension, in certain cases.
But for the most part, patents
are 20 years for everything
regardless, and copyrights
are life of the author,
that kind of thing.
It's the same.
So we don't really
distinguish it.
So I think one thing that would
be really useful is if
our intellectual property system
had more fine-grain
calibration along those lines.
Now does that mean you can't
learn anything from these
lower-investment examples?
I don't think so.
I think you have to be careful
about the lessons you draw.
So you can't just simply
kind of extrapolate.
So we don't look at the fashion
industry and say, oh,
that means we can get rid of
software patents, for example.
Though, actually, that might
not be a bad idea.
But they don't flow from
one another in any way.
But it does suggest that we need
to be careful about those
sorts of things.
You're absolutely right.
I think if we think about the
cost issue, though, we also
want to think about
the benefit side.
And when we start thinking
about benefits, this is a
bigger topic, but it's
not so much what
you actually receive.
It's what you think you will
receive through your
creativity or your innovation
that spurs your moment of
creation, your investment
in creation.
And I think we know from a
lot of work in behavioral
economics that people are very
bad at guessing in the future
how they will do.
So I know when I ask my
students, how will you do on
the exam in this class?
They're all going to get an A.
If you ask people who are
getting married, will
you get divorced?
People say no, even
though close to
50% will get divorced.
So we have optimism bias
built into us.
And that optimism bias
also plays out.
So cost is very important, but
you also want to think about,
how are benefits distributed?
This is a bigger topic, but
I'll leave it at that.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So the canonical
example that you're using of
places where there's been a lot
of fight about copying is
the music industry, but it
occurs to me that the copying
they're talking about is more
the counterfeit situation that
you described, versus the kind
of institutionalized way of
doing knockoffs.
Like cover recordings of a
same composer's work is
licensed, basically,
automatically.
KAL RAUSTIALA: Correct.
AUDIENCE: So it's interesting
to me that on the one hand,
they're fighting tooth-and-nail
this one kind
of copying, but they're really
good at benefiting from this
other kind.
I was wondering, are there
examples of places where an
industry was harmed before they
took on these kind of
copy protections?
Or is it mostly in places where
the copy protections
became part of the business
model, and then there was some
kind of tension?
KAL RAUSTIALA: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
So first of all, on the issue
of cover songs, just so
everyone understands.
So it's completely legal
to make a cover
version of a song.
The story's actually
really interesting.
We talk about it in the book.
It all stems from player pianos
and player piano rolls
back in the early
20th century.
That was the hot technology
at the time.
And as it was coming out, there
was a lot of concern
about this company called the
Aeolian Company, which maybe
was like the Google
of its day.
It was the dominant company.
Everybody was a little bit
worried about how much control
they would have.
And as a result, Congress,
lobbied by Aeolian's
competitors, passed this law
that basically said, you can
make a cover version of a song
as long as you pay a certain
statutory amount.
So the cover has always been
a part of recorded
music as we know it.
And by the way, there's no
evidence that covers--
of which, again, there
are many examples--
have in any way stopped
or constrained
creativity by musicians.
It's hard to know how to come at
that, but there's certainly
no evidence in favor of that
proposition that we can find.
OK.
So you started off by saying
that the online downloading
example is a little bit more
like counterfeiting.
It is, in some ways.
But that's not the only way
that copyright constrains
copying and music.
So if you think about sampling,
sampling is maybe a hybrid.
So you can take a short little
signature bit of a song--
and this was much more
common in the 1980s--
and plug it into your song, and
that was perfectly legal
at the time.
The courts have rapidly
constrained that to the point
where sampling is almost
always illegal today.
Even three notes--
just three notes of another
song-- have been held to be
illegal copying, infringing
of the copyright in
the original song.
So that's an extreme
understanding of it.
So it's just to say, yes, if you
just think about a digital
file that you find on the Pirate
Bay, or something,
that's one thing.
But there are many
other gradations.
And again, we talk about
this in greater detail.
The underlying question is
really, as I understood it, is
were there industries where
there wasn't copyright
protection, and then
they gained it, and
did anything change?
There are some.
Architecture's a good example.
So you didn't used
to be able to
protect the actual building.
So this building is pretty
unusual, right?
Binoculars.
You don't often see that.
Until the Architectural
Works Protection Act--
I can't remember the exact name
of that statute-- went
in, I think, 1990,
that changed it.
Now, are there more creative
buildings today than there
were before then?
That's a judgment call I
probably can't really make.
But my gut sense is no.
Not a big difference.
But you can also look
cross-nationally.
So fashion is unprotectable in
the United States, but it's
protected in Europe.
Is there a big difference in
terms of creative designs in
European designers versus
American designers?
Again, I don't think so.
The people who argue in favor of
changing American law point
to the ways in which, for
example, French law is more
protective of designers as
artists, and that that's more
appropriate.
But they don't really point to
the fact that the industry's
more vibrant, more
successful, more
creative, or anything else.
So there aren't that many over
time examples, but there are
cross-national examples,
and I think they tend
to support our view.
AUDIENCE: So if the two classic
industries described
as not having much copy
protection are cuisine and
fashion, if they were in the
process of potentially finding
out that they were about to come
under, let's say, design
patent coverage, which they
currently don't have.
So suppose they were going to
find out they were going to
get this, what would be the
reaction of the industry?
And how would the industry
change if that turned out to
be successful?
KAL RAUSTIALA: Good question.
By the way, just to mention the
other things we do talk
about in the book--
fonts, databases.
So databases are another one of
these cross-national ones
where they're unprotected.
The content, the layout
organization of the content,
unprotected in the United
States, protected in Europe.
Our database industry is
much more vibrant.
I mentioned fonts, financial
innovations,
and stand-up comedy.
So those are some of the other
ones we looked at.
But you're right, these are
some core examples.
The best one is really fashion,
because fashion,
that's actually a live issue
right now, not for design
patent but for copyright.
So there was currently a bill
introduced most recently by
Senator Schumer of New York to
amend the copyright statute to
create a three-year
quasi-copyright.
So it'd be very short and very
specific, but it would allow
for protection of some
of these dresses,
something like that.
It would allow for protection of
the overall design of that
dress, again, something that
was sort of quite similar.
So in other words, this kind
of knocking off would be
illegal, this kind of
exact knocking off.
Congress has considered
this several times.
And in fact, if you go back to
the Depression, you can find
examples of discussions about
the perils of copying.
So we quote this in the book,
a very interesting story in
"Time Magazine" from the 1930s
called "Dress Wars," which was
all about the New York garment
industry and the fact that
copying was happening
so rapidly--
within 24 hours, somebody would
copy a design from one
house to another house--
and how terrible that was.
At the time, there was something
called the Fashion
Originators' Guild, which was
what today we would consider
to be a kind of cartel,
a cartel of
designers and retailers.
And that policed copying
within its membership.
Ultimately, the Supreme Court
said that's an illegal
restraint of trade.
It violates the antitrust
laws.
It was overturned, 1941.
When it gets overturned, it's
the middle of World War II.
People aren't that focused
on fashion.
By the end of the war, the
original head of the guild and
the leaders of the fashion
industry in New York are
agitating before Congress to
say, we need a Fashion
Protection Act, a copyright
amendment, or else we're going
to lose hundreds of thousands
of jobs and
we're going to be destroyed.
And they've been saying
that ever since.
And again, it's continued to
be, in many ways, a very
vibrant industry.
Now, that's not to say they
won't get it this time.
So first of all, the industry
itself is split.
So if you talk to people here
in California, which is the
biggest center of garment
manufacturing in the United
States, the California Fashion
Association is totally opposed
to this bill.
The New York equivalent is in
favor, and is in fact the
motive force behind it.
So there's a division amongst
the industry about it.
If it were to pass, I think a
lot of bad things would occur.
I don't think it'd be terrible,
but I think there'd
be some bad things.
I think the main bad thing
would be, you would have
litigation over these kinds of
cases, which would be costly.
You would have to have a kind of
pre-clearance, if you were
a designer.
And a lot of these are small
mom-and-pop kind of
operations.
You'd have to have lawyers
around or lawyers on contract
to come and say, well, would
this be violative of--
you can find some differences,
if you look closely.
These are not great images,
but there are some
differences.
Would this be violative
of that?
And you'd have to be
consulted on it.
And then what happens
if you weren't sure?
And you'd start to get the kind
of clearance culture that
you see today in the film
industry in this town, where
people are very worried about,
in a documentary, let's say,
oh, if the TV's on in the
background, we gotta get
license because they're playing
"The Simpsons" or
something like that, or there's
a work of art or
whatever hanging on the wall.
So I think it would lead to--
it would be a boon for lawyers,
but I think it would
be costly for the industry.
And I think ultimately, it would
lead to less vibrant and
more creative industry.
And the reason I think that is
not that it's so terrible in
Europe, because it's not.
But Europe is a very different
legal climate.
There are many fewer lawyers.
There are often loser-pays
provisions.
So in other words, if I sue
you because I think you're
copying me, but you win, now I
have to pay all your fees.
We don't have that in
the United States.
So that's a constraint on
plaintiffs bringing cases.
And just in general, we're much
more litigious, and there
are many other features,
I think, that
make this more dangerous.
So I think the results would
ultimately not be--
I think the cure would be
worse than the disease.
Not that it wouldn't
stop certain--
this is kind of an egregious
example, and I feel bad for
the designers.
But I think at the end of the
day, as a policy matter, we're
better off with this system.
So actually, we testified before
Congress about this
very issue in opposition.
And my prediction is it's not
going to go anywhere, because
it hasn't for 75 years.
But someday, it might, and I
think it would be unfortunate.
Anything else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So one area that I
think is kind of interesting
with this sort of thing is video
games, where for some
types, like the web games, often
a smaller company will
innovate, and then a bigger
company will copy but with
better graphics and sort of lock
out the smaller company,
like in the case of the
"Farmville"-style games.
Then there's other areas, like
first-person shooters, where
the smaller companies innovate
and succeed based on that
because the bigger companies
are fighting over best
graphics or best story or things
that are peripheral to
the actual game.
And this sort of exists because
rules to a game are
one of those things you
can't copyright.
So I'm curious if there's other
industries where whether
you're small or big matters
to people's
attitudes about copying.
KAL RAUSTIALA: Yeah,
that's interesting.
Video games were one of the
things we wanted to look at,
and we just kind of
ran out of time.
I think it's a really
interesting area for it.
I do think smallness and
bigness does matter.
So I just mentioned
New York versus
California, in terms of apparel.
For the most part, the big
names, the names that you see
advertised in, let's say,
in "Vogue Magazine," are
concentrated in New York.
The LA apparel industry
is different.
We tend to focus here on
things like jeans--
virtually all denim products are
made here in LA County--
sportswear, surfwear obviously,
a lot of casual
clothing, often with labels that
are not that well-known
or not that big.
So you could argue that that's
an example where there's a
small/big kind of issue.
Now that said, the arguments
that are often given in
Congress for apparel protection
are that small
designers are hurt by the
current system and would be
better off if they
were protected.
Because they get swallowed by
the big guy, who says--
Forever 21--
it was Foley & Corinna who were
the designers for this
dress, small designers
with a store in New
York and one in LA.
Not a big operation, a few
million dollars a year, versus
Forever 21, which
is a monster.
So that's often the
way it's seen.
But I don't know that
that's really true.
Because again, I think big
companies have big lawyers,
and big lawyers know how
to write letters
that intimidate others.
And so I'm not sure that
that's actually
how it would work.
You know, in the culinary
context, it's similar.
The people who really care about
patent and copyright in
cuisine are not the chefs
at great restaurants.
It's the people who own big
food companies that sell
things like frozen foods.
So someone who kind of
crossed over would be
like Wolfgang Puck.
So he started off with
restaurants like the one down
the street.
But then he now has a gigantic
empire, and those people tend
to start to care more, because
they have bigger investments.
So I think there is a divide,
but I think it's sort of
industry by industry.
It is an interesting issue.
And then it's an interesting
question, do we always want to
protect small businesses
versus big ones?
And if so, why?
That's across the board.
I don't think there's an
obvious answer to that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like
there's a couple things that
I've noticed that maybe color
the copying, or aren't exactly
just sort of the
act of copying,
that affect the situation.
Maybe in fashion, it's
that the trademark
sometimes is the product.
With football and the small
chefs, there's a big execution
component to it.
KAL RAUSTIALA: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: The small chefs and
the big food industries.
Are there other things like
that, in other industries,
that affect the copying
or the trade-offs?
KAL RAUSTIALA: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think just to riff on the
execution point for a second,
that's a really good point.
So execution is really
important.
And I think one of the points we
make is that if you want to
protect yourself against
copying, the more you can
shift your product from a
digital or easily-copied
product-- especially
a digital product--
to an analog product, the
better off you are.
Another thing we talk about in
the book, kind of at the end
of the chapter on food, is
cocktails and high-end bars.
So those are a really good
example, where bartenders have
a very open culture, again, a
kind of quasi-open-source
environment for bartenders.
There's a lot of creativity
in cocktails.
But the execution is
really important.
But even more important is that
when you get a drink,
it's really like-- sitting
at a bar is like a live
performance venue.
That's really what it's about.
You could take that same exact
drink and put it in your
cafeteria here, and you're not
going to pay $12 for it.
You probably don't pay anything
for your cafeteria.
[LAUGHTER]
KAL RAUSTIALA: But you
know what I mean?
It's not the same thing.
And the same thing
with restaurants.
It's not the same thing.
And so that live element
is difficult to copy.
Same thing with music.
So one of the most successful
areas of the music industry
right now is live performance.
And I think the ability to copy
is pushing things more
and more into live
performance.
And so that has advantages if
you're concerned about ease of
copying in a world where
bandwidth is increasing, and
you're just going to be
able to kind of--
yes, you can record live
concerts, but it's not the
same thing as being there.
So experiential factors become
increasingly significant.
And that can play a role for
a lot of industries.
So even the movie industry,
it's under siege by the
ability to stream at home.
And obviously, all the torrent
sites make it really easy.
But yet the Arclight Cinemas are
doing really well and have
gone from being one location
on Sunset Boulevard to now
having four, even though they
charge almost double what the
national average is
for a ticket.
Why is that?
I'm sure a lot of you have
gone to the Arclight.
It's because you go, it's
kind of special.
The seats are great,
the viewing is
great, you get a drink.
It feels like an event.
It's not just a consumption
of a digital product.
It's a live performance, even
though it's not really a live
performance.
So all of those things, I think,
make those industries
more successful.
So the more you can shift in
that direction, towards
something where it's live and
execution-oriented and
personalized, the better.
That doesn't work for
everything, but it does work,
I think, for many industries,
if you're creative about it.
Well, thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]